je ne me poserai pas je l ai déjà dit ce
ne prendrait pas position par contre je
vais continuer de regarder les
programmes économiques
je peux vous dire que plus détaillé
aujourd'hui le plus pragmatique la suite
françois fillon d'accord que j'attends
beaucoup d' emmanuel macron parce que je
n'ai rien ou presque rien aujourd'hui
vous vous attardez pas ce que vous avez
beaucoup d'espoir aussi mais parce qu'il
n'est pas encore sorti donc voilà si lio
je louerai rétro et vous aviez tout à
fait intéressant mais c'est intéressant
sur le sur l'aspect vous connaissez la
personnalité mccoleman macron il ya des
régions des gens qui aiment et 90e - il
voit la presse et des questions de
personne mais sur le programme on tombe
de haut vol mg 1 mais non j'ai écouté
c'est un problème si vous vous souvenez
il était venu dire j'aime l'entreprise
lors de votes mais ça c'est manuel valls
qui est venu des entreprises
je voulais aussi ils disent la même
chose de quoi effectivement ça protège
les répètes ailleurs et non mais toi il
faut pas faux pas il faut être précis
sourire on parle d'une présidence de la
république française dans une situation
où la france est en train de décrocher
doucement mais sûrement et qu'il faut il
faut faire des réformes solides
rationnelle pragmatique autour de
l'économie autour d'entreprises
si on veut régler problème du chômage et
un centre de d'autres choses redonner
espoir aux français
et bien c'est par l'emploi l'emploi
c'est l'entreprise donc c'est tout ce
qui part d'une entreprise
j'espère qu'il en parle comme ça et en
effet ça fonctionnera ce qui n'en parle
pas du tout aussi c'est uniquement pour
dire on va au contraindre on va
augmenter les impôts on va augmenter les
dépenses et bien ça non je suis désolé
parce que là vous allez vous retrouver
avec un taux de chômage immense et des
sur entreprises qui vont être
complètement démotivée justement de ces
candidats à l'élection présidentielle
vous allez recevoir pierre gattaz camp
écoutez il est prévu qu'on fasse des
matinées avec les dizaines ou la
douzaine de candidats majeurs je dirais
et ceux également qui auront eu leur
investiture en fait leur leur signature
il ya des parcelles et net de prévu je
pense que ce sera à partir du 15 mars 12
mars 15 mars jusqu'au 15 avril